bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport je suis ravi de
vous retrouver tout de suite on passe au
sommaire golf la 99e édition de l'open
de france est terminée ce dimanche au
golf national de guyancourt
l'autrichien bernd wiesberger 39e joueur
mondial a créé la sensation en
s'imposant en 50 ans livin été taillé
dans cette édition
cyclisme nous ferons le bilan de cette
saison coup de projecteur à suivre sur
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste et sur la compétition sur
route paris nice nous recevrons dans
quelques instants quentin lafargue
médaille de bronze le 8 l/100 février
dernier ian dury notre consultant
cyclisme taekwondo yanis gonis 14 ans
est devenu champion de france de la
discipline à toulon conséquence le
trappistes participera un test match
pour se qualifier au championnat du
monde entre a su dans ce magazine
et puis en fin d'émission nous parlerons
football et des résultats de l'équipe de
football de trappes seniors
la 99e édition de l'open de france a
livré son verdict ce dimanche au golf
national de guyancourt
l'autrichien bernd wiesberger 39e joueur
mondial a créé la sensation en
s'imposant pour la première fois sur les
greens saint quentin en yvelines
victor dubuisson le français a terminé à
la 12e place à lessines
les images sont signés mélanie poké à
l'image de la météo caniculaire pluies
orageuses cette 99e édition de l'open de
france de golf a été totalement
imprévisible avant le tournoi les
spécialistes de la petite balle blanche
parier sur le double tenant du titre
graeme mcdowell ou encore l'anglais lee
westwood
mais c'est finalement l'autrichien bernd
wiesberger 39e mondial qui a raflé la
mise
viennois de 29 ans a conclu son open
avec une carte de 65 soit 13 coups sous
le par
une journée parfaite ponctuée par quatre
berdier la suite entre le trou numéro 4
et le trou numéro 7
je pense que je suis très chanceux
d'avoir remporté ce tournoi j'ai bien
joué sur ce beau terrain avec un swing
très bon j'avais confiance en moi et
c'est très important quand on veut
remporter des titres sur le circuit nos
jeunes concitoyens
c'est un magnifique vainqueur il a très
bien joué aujourd'hui il a fait un tour
à -6 les spécialistes apprécieront dans
des conditions même puisqu'il faisait
beau mais néanmoins chaude avec du vent
il a su maîtriser l'ensemble des
éléments sur un parcours de grande
qualité
le premier fond c'est michael lorenzo
vera termine à une belle sixième place
avec une carte de 68 devant victor
dubuisson la nouvelle star du golf
français 4e à l'entamé de la dernière
journée s'est totalement effondrée ce
dimanche il a réalisé une carte de 75
avec une balle dans l'eau dès le trou
numéro 1 et balle hors limites au trou
numéro 7
une journée à oublier pour le provençal
c'est une partie aurait même sans aucune
réussite malheureusement j'ai raté un
jeu fait un drive moyens qui sera fini
voilà c'est un peu le résumé
n'appartient des choses positives c'est
sur mais bon c'est mon objectif et pas
de vie cette place là c'est un champion
il prend le départ c'est pas pour être
deuxième c'est correct premier je crois
qu'il faut lui rendre hommage parce
qu'il a su animer le tout ces partis
hier aujourd'hui et on sentait dès ce
matin une volonté d'aboutir sur la plus
haute marche du podium
je suis tranquille ce n'est que partie
remise
victor dubuisson devrait revenir l'année
prochaine sur le parcours du golf
national et il tentera de s'imposer pour
la centième édition de l'open de france
de golf
cette victoire de l'autre l'autrichien
bernd wiesberger a fait frissonner les
fans du golf national ils étaient encore
plus de 60000 cette année à suivre la
compétition notamment les parties des
français remarque fini pour le montage
comme chaque année l'open de france de
golf a fait le plein ils étaient encore
plus de 60000 au bord des greens du golf
national de guyancourt pour suivre les
exploits des sportifs
dans le public on pouvait apercevoir des
passionnés mais également de nouveaux
fans nous c'est la première fois qu'on
vient en fait on est on est tous tout
récent golfeurs et j'ai eu l'occasion de
voir les billets en vente sur internet
on a récupéré d'oublier les tester de
venir voir comment ça se passe et une
compétition de golf
donc voilà on est venu et et c'est
vachement sympa on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
de plus en plus de nouveaux gopher
qu'ils viennent découvrir un petit peu
la peine son ambiance son image qu est
ce qu un appel
on sent une évolution puis deux trois
ans et je trouve que c'est bénéfique
pour ma discipline
du beau monde également dans les loges
une dizaine d'athlètes ou ex sportifs
venus de toutes les disciplines ont
assisté à la compétition
je viens tous les ans depuis dp quelques
années voilà c'est ça vous plaît le
golfe jimmy mais je m'immerge haut rhin
c'est pas encore ça
on a la chance d'avoir l'une des
meilleures compétitions en europe et
avec la ryder cup qui va arriver en
france donc tout simplement c'est il
faut être ici quand on aime le golfe et
voilà notre hymne national l'open de
france de golf est également rendez vous
international près d'un tiers des
spectateurs sont étrangers je suis le
parcours de brendan steele en ce moment
il joue sur le terrain d'à côté c'est un
joueur américain
je le suis surtout sur le circuit pilier
je suis venu pour voir cet événement
magnifique tv organisé et pouvoir aussi
les meilleurs joueurs d'année nous avons
assisté depuis 2007 je pense 2007
naissance ici c'est de chaque année pour
assister au repas degroof nous avons
nous avons beaucoup le le parcours ici
c'est super bon super bon et on a
toujours en tête de rat de coptes au
mileu 2018 la ryder cup 2018 devrait
attirer près de 60000 personnes mais
cette fois-ci par jour les spectateurs
sont déjà impatients après le golf on
passe maintenant au cyclisme
pour ce dernier cette huit sports de la
saison coup de projecteur aujourd'hui
sur le cyclisme dans les yvelines la
saison vélo a été très riche en émotions
cette année il ya notamment eu les
championnats du monde sur piste en
février dernier puis paris nice en mars
pour nous parler de ces deux
compétitions nous recevons sur ce
plateau le pistard de l'équipe de france
quant à la fargue dont qui a été
médaillé de bronze lors des derniers
championnats du monde mais également
yann dujarrier notre consultant cyclisme
est également champion d'europe sur
piste en 2013 alors nous allons débuter
cette page cyclistes par les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste
quand on peut dire que c'était vraiment
une belle fête populaire
ces champions ouais une très belle
réussite le public a répondu présent
cinq mille spectateurs tous les jours et
puis et puis voilà une belle fête pour
le cyclisme français aussi puisque voilà
la france dans son ensemble a vraiment
une super résultat ce vélodrome
yann il a fait beaucoup de bruit pendant
les cinq jours de compétition
surtout quand les français étaient en
piste c'était le côté très chauvin de
nos spectateurs des spectateurs français
de toute façon en général et c'est vrai
que dès que nos français était sûr été
sur le bois l'ambiance était été
formidable quand on peut dire que la
france a réussi ses championnats du
monde il ya eu sept médailles dont 5 en
or la france a vraiment réussi c'est le
champion du oui et puis surtout on
retrouve le premier rang mondial au
classement des nations donc ça c'est
c'est une belle satisfaction pour pour
l'ensemble de l'épi de l'équipe
ces voix là on que ce soit chez les
sprinteurs ou même au niveau de
l'endurance
une belle réussite au niveau des
championnats du monde de super résultat
yann ce résultat il était inespéré il
était envisageable il était comment
serait complètement visage et même pas
simplement envisageable vraiment visage
et on savait que nos gars sur le sprint
serait répondrai présent
la seule vraie surprise qu'on peut que
l'on peut donner ce serait la médaille
de bronze du poursuiteur en individuel
mais mais voilà quoi le reste tout le
monde a répondu présent et quentin a
confirmé ce qu'il avait zappé le
troisième parce qu'il avait réalisé
depuis depuis quelques saisons au niveau
niveau national là il est allé chercher
le résultat qu'on attendait au niveau
international il ya aussi un homme qui
n'a pas déçu qui était attendu c'était à
françois pervis il avait trois titres en
colombie il avait acquis trois sites en
colombie il en a gagné deux sur ces
championnats du monde en keirin et
également sur le kilomètre finalement il
était attendu mais il a répondu présent
il était attendu mais c'était quand même
c'était quand même 2 il a vraiment fait
avec la classe et au moral parce que ben
il a eu beaucoup de pain sur sur sa
préparation hivernale pour pour ces
championnats du monde
il n'était pas aussi ce qui pouvait
l'être auparavant
là il a il a démontré que qu'il était un
cran au dessus sur sur ces disciplines
sur kg / sur le keirin ça a été vraiment
vraiment super de pouvoir voir kiki
qu'il était là toujours quoi c'était
super moi j'ai vraiment vraiment adoré
parce que c'est un gars sympa qui est
facile d'accès qui est donc bah ça fait
plaisir de voir qu'ils continuent et
puis surtout un gars qui est arrivé sur
le tard donc non voilà non c'est une
belle une belle satisfaction quentin
vous qui ai côtoyé françois pervis s'est
vraiment mérité également ça oui c'est
au titre
oui mérité toute façon on bosse tous
pour la même chose après c'est vrai
qu'un à qui ont plus de réussite que
d'autres françois a été très très fort
en en 2014 et comme l'a dit yann il a
connu quelques difficultés au cours de
l'hiver il a chuté sur la dernière
manche de coupe du monde donc bien sûr
que c est mérité puisqu'il travaille
comme un fou pour aller chercher pour
aller chercher ces maillots et ses
médailles aux championnats du monde
mais voilà ça pourrait être nommé et et
pour n'importe lequel d'entre nous parce
que bascule mine de rien il y en a qui
réussissent mais en a qui travaillent
tout autant et qui qui galère un peu
plus donc voila c'était un très beau
championnat du monde avec des bons
résultats pour la france il ya un autre
pistard qui a également impressionné sur
ces championnats du monde c'est
également de gohi baugé il vous a battu
d'ailleurs en demi-finale sur la vitesse
qu'est ce qu'il a pu scorer baugé est ce
qui là est ce que pointent sans pour
vous la marche est peut-être un peu trop
haute
le djia est là trente ans que y aura
quelques puisque moi et puis donc un peu
plus d'expérience et
voilà greg on connait son palmarès il a
été quatre fois champion du monde de
vitesse individuelle entre 2009 et 2012
il redevient cette année champion du
monde de vitesse individuelle c'est un
gars qui a vraiment beaucoup
d'expérience et qui se pince est une
force de la nature
physiquement il a un peu un peu dingue
est ce qu'il ya des médailles qui ont
peut-être je sais pas un peu surpris on
qu'on n'attendait pas forcément je pense
par exemple à bryan coquard sur
l'américaine american on avait l'équipe
qui était grosse favorite
il a les cannes gars qu'ils auraient pu
je pense m'être dans n'importe quelle
dans n'importe quelles possibilités et
sa position je pense que les cats
étaient capables d'être champions du
monde des champions du monde ils ont ça
a été une très belle épreuve
il a fallu vraiment se bagarrer contre
les anglais qui avaient pris qui avait
pris le tour et puis au final avec avec
l'italien sajoo 1 point yanis et pas
n'importe qui quand même hein donc mais
non voilà il était hyper serein et brian
a vraiment vraiment galéré sur sur les
25 derniers tours il a vraiment été
chercher se chercher les derniers
sprints et dernier point et et voilà non
il appert a été a été superbe et et
voilà sd4 et je pense que les quatre
aurait été champion du monde quoi qu'il
en soit sur sur cette épreuve à l'heure
chez les hommes ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné par contre chez les femmes
c'est un peu plus compliqué nous avons
rencontré 110 clair la plaisir oiseaux
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines
nous sommes avec le plaisir oise 110
clair la pistarde de l'équipe de france
ensemble nous allons revenir sur les
résultats de l'équipe de france féminine
aux championnats du monde sur piste qui
ont eu lieu ici à saint quentin en
yvelines alors 110s que les résultats
des françaises étaient à la hauteur des
espérances
non c'est vrai que malheureusement on
n'a pas cédé résultats espérés on était
en dessous de ce qu'on aurait pu faire
voilà il ya quand même quelques bonnes
choses au niveau des chronos mais voilà
au niveau des résultats on est très loin
des podiums donc
on va encore travailler énormément parce
que les jeux c'est dans un an donc on a
encore à la fois le temps est à la fois
pas le temps de ce que ça va arriver
très vite mais voilà on a repris un
programme d'entraînement très structuré
et du coup je pense qu'on a une bonne
marge de progression nous les féminines
et qu'est-ce qui a manqué peut-être aux
pisteurs de l'équipe de france sur ces
championnats du monde
alors là c'est une bonne question parce
que on s'entraîne comme les garçons qui
sont votées entraînement peut-être non
je pense que l'entraînement est très bon
mais voilà c'était peut-être un jour
sans pour nous tout et c'est difficile à
expliquer parce qu'on n'était pas
forcément en méforme et du cou
voilà c'est bon a pris à la tactique
aussi qui rentrent en jeu et ça c'est on
peut pas dire que ça vient
d'entraînement moi je pense qu
entraînement est très bon mais voilà je
pour l'expliquer c'est très très dur a
expliqué on sait pas forcément pourquoi
est ce qu'il ya eu des pistards
peut-être qu'ils aient eu un petit peu
surpris sur ces championnats du monde
défi qu'on n'attendait pas forcément
nationale ne vous le dirais que non
pascal sur sa troisième place qui vont
malheureusement été déclassés voilà le
scratch on sait très bien qu'elle est
très forte sur ça après virginie a fait
un très bon temps sur le 500 mètres donc
c'était je pense à huy une bonne
surprise après voilà étant donné qu'on
n'a pas eu d'énormes résultat on ne peut
pas dire qu'il ya eu vraiment beaucoup
de surprises mais qu'est-ce qu'il faudra
peut-être améliorer notre pointe de
vitesse est plus forte à aller plus vite
parce que forcément fait des sprints
donc
on se bat contre les autres mais aussi
contre le chrono donc c'est important
d'aller plus vite et pour pouvoir aller
plus loin dans les tournois et pourquoi
pas ramener
merci beaucoup sans nucléaire si quand
on l'a vu avec sandie clair les
résultats des féminines n'ont pas
forcément été à la hauteur sur ces
championnats du monde à la hauteur jouit
à disons que ça a été un peu plus
compliqué que pour les garçons après
comme comme on vient d'en entendre sans
lui parler et elle ont le même
entraînement que nous peut-être je sais
pas le sprint c'est tellement une
discipline qui peut être aléatoire sur
le plan tactique sur le plan moral fait
prendre l'ascendant sur son adversaire
c'est ça veut pas dire que tu es plus
fort physiquement tu peux aussi le
prendre de façon voilà le bouffées
mentalement
du coup je suis pas capable de dire ce
qui a été bien ou moins bien maintenant
les filles bosse très bien et je leur
souhaite vraiment de pouvoir progresser
surtout dans l'année qui qui arrivent
via nous est plutôt optimiste ou
pessimiste sur les françaises aux jo par
exemple la prochaine arrive complètement
optimistes elles ont elles sont
régulièrement dans l'est dans les têtes
ouais dans l'oeuf un vrai dans les têtes
et vous sur les podiums sur les manches
de coupe du monde ou si on les rencontre
qui peut y avoir sur sur d'autres
d'autres épreuves
donc ya pas de y'a pas de raison voilà
c'était un une semaine une semaine
maudite pour les féminines pas oublier
que on en a une qui a été déclassé sur
le scratch en est d'autres qui finit
quatrième de la course aux points enfin
voilà ça s'est joué des fois des tout
petits détails
non ben voilà c'est juste pas de c'était
juste pas le bon moment
ça viendra et il faut que juste continue
de travailler pour pour la suite
l'actualité du cyclisme de résister
également paris nice qui était organisé
au mois de mars il ya eu un michel
caquot ski qui avait remporté la course
c'était une très belle course yann ce
paris nice qui s'est déroulé à côté de
maurepas par exemple un contre la montre
contre la montre comme ça dans l'est sur
les rues de fin mai dans l'est sur saint
quentin en yvelines
c'était c'est très très bien organisé un
beau un beau spectacle toujours
public présent et chauvin je me souviens
dans la côte dans la côte où dès qu'on
avait un français kiki passait c'était
c'était vraiment très très déco rose en
cours à de gros l'encouragement donc une
très belle journée aussi il avait fait
un super temps au mois de mars
donc tout était tout était réuni voilà
c'est le les yvelines c'est une terre de
l'inter de cyclisme oublier qu'au mois
d'août de cette année vous aurez enfin
on aura le départ de paris brest paris
qui partira du redon et saint quentin en
yvelines
il va y avoir plusieurs milliers de
cyclistes qui vont qu'ils vont faire
1200 km en l'espace de trois jours moi
c'est quand je travaillais sur
saint-quentin j'adorais en partant du
boulot croisé croiser ces cyclistes qui
était tous fatigués qui rentraient de
leurs 2 lors de leur deux trois jours de
faim les trois-quatre jours de vélo il
faut pas oublier de remettre un petit
coup de klaxon ou un petit coup
d'accélérateur ou de félicitations parce
que ben à leur niveau ce sont aussi des
héros et voilà non ben ça fait partie de
toute l'ambiance et de tout ce que les
yvelines peuvent apporter au cyclisme
dans l'île de france quentin on va
refermer cette page cyclisme par le tour
de france on est obligé d'en parler
pour vous est-ce qu'il ya un favori qui
se dégage sur le tour de france qui vous
pourriez a misé une petite pièce je veux
pas m'y amuse une pièce il ya ya ya
quatre grands favoris je crois contador
from nibali et et condamna du coup moi
je suis un cycliste donc je vais
forcément suivre ce tour de france
maintenant je vais aussi beaucoup si
vous les copains dabistes avec brian kee
sur sur le tour damien gaudin qui aussi
qu' aussi sur les routes de son premier
tour de france donc voila moi je veux
être plus supporters des gens que je
connais merci à tous les deux d'être
passé sur ce plateau il ya non vous
retrouver à la rentrée pour commander le
cyclisme dans les yvelines
quand un bon courage pour la suite de
votre saison merci vous continuerez à
vous suivre
on passe maintenant au taekwondo
en mai dernier
yanis gomis 14 ans est devenu champion
de france de taekwondo à toulon en
finale il a terminé sa compétition par
ak ou conséquence il est qualifié pour
participer un test-match en juillet pour
participer au championnat du monde
portrait de ce champion qui n'a pas
froid aux yeux les images sont signés et
le diwan il ya les et gomis 14 ans et
l'étoile montante du taekwondo français
le sportif licencié à trappes a commencé
à pratiquer cet art martial coréen en
2010 sous les conseils de son père
françois
ce dernier a été champion les yvelines
dans sa jeunesse c'est mon sport de vie
moi j'ai commencé le taekwondo de
pédaler depuis 89 1989
ensuite lui je lui est entré à l'âge de
8 ans il avait fait un tout petit peu de
foot avant et on a découvert qu'on va le
taekwondo c'était un sport pour lui
couple puisque moi je suis pas trop ce
sport collectif c'est plus un sport
individuel et
et voilà ça a payé à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui et ça risque de payer
encore beaucoup et il est parti pour
faire une succession de fous aujourd'hui
sont simplement suffi à effrayer ses
adversaires champion départemental et
d'ile-de-france le sportif a ajouté
cette année le titre de champion de
france à son palmarès
un résultat qui va lui permettre de
participer un test-match en juillet une
victoire lui permettrait de se qualifier
pour les championnats du monde et de
s'envoler pour la corée du sud
ça me fait plaisir j'étais choquée parce
que je ne pensais pas à y aller ranger
et ça m'a fait plaisir à moi et ma
famille mon père parlait au chocolat ou
un jean genet année et dallas a réalisé
six sélectionnés et végétaux faire pour
pour son test match le 23 juillet le
jeune taekwondoïste amateurs du coup de
pied retourné misera sur son point fort
le physique
à 14 ans il mesure près d'un mètre
soixante dix huit pour 64 kg malgré ces
facilités yanis peut encore progresser
au point faible et je devais toujours su
travailler la souplesse en fait que
yanis devra gommer pour se qualifier
pour les championnats du monde et viser
une médaille pendant la compétition sera
pas terminé à une très belle quatrième
place en promotion d'honneur après un
début de saison compliqué l'équipe s'est
bien redressée en deuxième partie de
saison
nous recevons sur ce plateau mustapha
larbaoui le président de trappes et les
deux défenseurs du club stéphane
fernandez et hamidou sissoko
bonsoir bonsoir mustapha larfaoui
comment expliquer ce revirement de
situation vous étiez à la limite de la
relégation finalement finalement que
vous a plutôt bien traversé championnat
bah en fait il ya eu 2
deux temps forts effectivement il ya eu
un moment où on a on a frôlé le carton
rouge contre pour tout dire et puis ça
s'est vite rétablie sur pareil on est
parti avec un groupe
au complet et puis on a quand même suivi
des défaillances
on va dire technique avec
essentiellement des problèmes de gardien
de but qui ont fait très très mal à la
défense jean temps pour le pour les buts
encaissés très très peu efficaces devant
trop peu pardon efficace devant et puis
relativement compliquée dans l'est dans
les buts
et puis au final on a un gardien de but
qui est arrivé et qui a réussi à
redresser la barre mais surtout nos amis
la défense a déjà intégré beaucoup de
buts cette saison
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce que pourquoi
enfin qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
justement défend cette année peut-être
la solidarité entre le joueur qu'est ce
qui a fait la différence pour la plupart
on se connaissait déjà depuis quelques
années
la défense est un secteur au niveau
duquel il ya pas eu beaucoup de
changements donc je pense que c'est ce
qui a fait la différence
stéphane qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui
a fait la différence aussi ce revirement
de situation finalement en décembre
février où vous êtes limite de la
relégation vous vous remportez ensuite
tous vos matches
vers la fin de saison qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui a changé peut-être le discours du
coach
peut-être non je pense que c'est parce
qu'au début d'année j'ai commencé en
réserve
elle arrivait justement décembre et ça
correspond tout à fait à mes victoires
et à l'aller sauveur il a dit que la
saison avait été grâce à ces deux là
pour ça qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
mais c'est parfois en même temps à ce
que dit stéphane parce que alors bien
sûr c'est sous le ton de la plaisanterie
mais pas tant que ça il a laissé passer
d'autres personnes avant lui mais voilà
en réserve en réserve c'est très
technique mais en même temps c'est très
très très psychologique mais ceci pour
dire que stéphane et et hamidou sont
avec moi depuis plus de dix ans ils
étaient les étés en u17 u19 avant ils
sont montés en seniors il ya à peu près
une dizaine d'années on va on a les
enfants de trappes
on a les joueurs de trappes on a les
gens qu'ils ont su attendre et conçu
donné quand il fallait combat c'est
l'état d'esprit du club de trappes et
s'acheter un insoumis aujourd'hui il y
en a quelques-uns comme ça il y en a
d'autres qui sont pas là aujourd'hui
mais il ya un vrai état d'esprit surtout
et à ce qu'il ya peut être des regrets
sur cette saison finale parce que vous
avez bien ça la fin mai mais pourquoi
enfin le début a pas été forcément très
concluants ce qui est des regrets
match peut-être que vous avez loupé que
vous n'auriez pas dû louper oui
forcément si on regarde le nombre de
matches nuls losique mais énormément
cette saison c'est comment expliquer
justement ces matches nuls peut-être le
l'envi envie de m'avancer mais perdent
on peut être le ballon pas forcément
parce que c'est des matches où souvent
on menait au score
donc ça presse et psychologique c'était
sur une série
mais bon je pense qu'il faudra se servir
de ça pour l'année prochaine travailler
là dessus je pense que donc ça fera la
différence
neuf matches et c'est conséquent quand
même sur une saison c'est au final neuf
matches nuls pour finir quatrième je
n'ai pas fait le calcul mais ça doit
être du genre deux trois matches qui
basculait en notre faveur ou qui
n'auraient pas dû basculer en notre
défaveur
on était premiers parce que c'est ça
s'est joué à très peu de chose quand
même un petit détail
ouais moi je pense que voilà c'était
trop trop stérile en attaque puisque on
défonce ils ont vraiment fait le boulot
donc on en a encaissé pour des raisons
que j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
vraiment deux gardiens de but de très
très bon niveau
qui se sont qui se sont cassés entre
guillemets l'entraînement et puis on a
un gardien de but qui est arrivé en
cours de saison qui a du mal à prendre
ses marques mais qui nous a fait un très
très belle fin de saison abdoulaye
je tiens à préciser qu'elle fait un très
bon boulot avec la défense mostapha
larbaoui la saison prochaine c'est la
montée alors oui parce qu'on est des
proches finalement oui oui parce que on
est compétiteur donc un président qui
dit on monte pas ce serait ce serait
dramatique je dirais presque pour l'état
d'esprit mais bon on verra au fur et à
mesure parce que nos amis sont là ils
seront là l'année prochaine
il y en a d'autres qui sont au film on
finit bien donc on devrait bien
commencer on devrait bien perdurer cela
étant c'est très long et puis ya de la
concurrence mais on va pas se voiler la
face
oui bien sûr on va essayer de on va tout
faire on est compétiteur mais mais mais
mais il ya des mets donc lundi où la
possibilité aussi mais on est en
compétition mais globalement on va tout
faire pour bien sûr le message est passé
en tout cas merci à vous trois d'être
passé sur ce plateau continuera à suivre
trappe la saison prochaine c'est la fin
de cette fuite sport merci d'avoir suivi
merci d'avoir suivi ce magazine tout au
long de la saison je vous retrouve à la
rentrée prochaine d'ici là passer
d'excellentes vacances très bel été sur
tv fil 78